alright Sean Murphy I've heard faith
I've heard for years that you need to be
able to perform clean comedy I try hard
to write clean meaning I don't curse a
lot but my subject matter always ends up
adult what's your opinion on clean
comedy hate to say it's Shawnie murder
Doug but it is very helpful very almost
almost necessary I mean even David tells
like the funniest kind of planning so
he's got a jokes and his his he's
got clean he can write clean he can do
it so I think it's imperative if you
want to do balland you want to do all
these late nights you got to have it so
it's a good way to get in the door I'm
not saying it's you I'm not saying it's
your voice or your path rather for
forever but I think it's good to have
and it suck it up and and try to
make it work like let's say you're an
amazing wrestler and you want to do the
MMA you got to learn boxing you got a
box a little so have it in your corner
you know I'm not saying it's got to be
your future career what's the opposite
of temporary permanent thank you say
your permanent world but try it knock it
out and it's harder it is harder I will
say as a comic I can admit clean it's
harder dirty is easier I'm not saying
dirty is bad I'm not saying dirty tack
but it's easier because sex we're gonna
laugh cursing we're gonna laugh so
challenge yourself by trying to write
some clean yeah and if you didn't have
clean you wouldn't be able to open for a
Seinfeld exactly exactly and I trust me
I just sift through albums of stuff
mm-hmm to find the cleanest that's
like his level clean and I'm I'll tell
you what I'm glad I had it hey hot
brother and sister-in if you love comedy
as much as we do here at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath averse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips